[Music]
should tech platforms be liable for what
users post online in 1996 Congress said
they shouldn't section 230 of the
Communications Decency Act protects
platforms from lawsuits based on
user-generated content a person who says
they were harmed by material posted
online has to go after whoever posted it
not the platform on which it was posted
but with controversy swirling around big
tech some are arguing that CDA 230
should go away that would probably be a
mistake without CDA 230 platforms might
either ban user-generated content or
refuse to moderate it because of the
risk of being treated as an author of a
publisher lawsuits could swamp their
small competitors if we could go back in
time it might have been better to let
common law courts determine the rules a
common rule of no liability for
platforms would have been better than
immunity given by Congress because that
will be a political football forever CDA
230 he was a huge vibrant social media
environment we've got today even though
some bad actors get a pass we should
probably keep that sensible liability
rule rather than experimenting with
something new what do you think about
CDA 230 should Congress reform it repeal
it or leave it in place let us know in
our poll also let us know what other
topics you'd like scholars to cover